[Music]
Well, hello dear friends. Thank you so
much for joining us on our program I'd
Like to Know. As probably many of you
know, this is a question and answer
program that airs every week here at
Secrets Unsealed and Some TV. We take
your questions that you send us. We put
them in the order in which we receive
them and then we answer the questions on
the air. So I want to encourage you to
please send questions to us. We have
lots of them. We might might not answer
your question in the very next program
because we receive many many questions
but we can never receive uh enough
questions because eventually we will
answer all of them. Uh if you want to
send us your questions, you'll see on
the screen the email address where you
can send them to us. TV
tvsumtv.orgg. In other words,
tvsumtv.org. We'd be delighted to get
your questions. I have with me two
distinguished uh workers here at Secrets
Unsealed. my good friend CA Murray to my
right hand and to my left hand Pastor
David Salasar who is in charge of our
Spanish programming here at Secrets
Unsealed. Good to have both of you here.
Thank you, Pastor. Good to be here
always. Praise the Lord. Okay, we have
some very uh captivating questions today
and we trust that uh the answers that we
give will be beneficial to those who are
watching. Uh I just want to uh have a
word of prayer before we actually begin.
And so I'd like to ask uh maybe Pastor
Salasad if he would pray for us.
Absolutely. Let us pray. Gracious
heavenly father, we come before you to
ask that you will give us a portion of
the Holy Spirit as we open your word. We
want to be guided by you and we want to
answer according to your will. give us
the wisdom, give us the clarity, give uh
us the words to speak that it may bring
people closer to you and to
understanding of your word. I pray this
in Jesus name. Amen. Amen. Amen. Well,
before we actually get to our first
question, I have an announcement that I
would like to make. Uh as probably many
of you know, the general conference
session is taking place this year uh in
St. Louis, Missouri from July 3 July
12th of this year. And uh Secrets
Unsealed is going to be at booth number
107 at our um general conference session
this year. Uh we are going to have a
large exhibit there. We're going to be
uh recording testimonies. We have uh
individuals who are going to be going uh
different places at the general
conference session uh you know doing
short interviews. We're going to have a
newscast every day in the afternoon. Um,
we are also going to record live I'd
like to know in English and meustia in
Spanish and those will be aired
afterwards there at the general
conference
session also. We are going to uh tape
live uh several Sabbath school classes.
So if you want to know how we do Sabbath
school that you watch every week, uh
please come by our booth and you'll be
able to see uh how the program is taped
for you to see on a weekly basis. So we
hope to see you come by. We'd love to
greet you and we'd like to love to get
your testimony. uh it would be a delight
for us to know where you come from and
what your spiritual walk with the Lord
is. So now we want to go into ourh
questions uh for today. And the first
question comes from Will. And of course,
where there's a will, there's a way.
Amen. And so maybe we could have CA
Murray read the question. All righty.
Thank you, Will. We are always told in
our Adventist church to study our Bibles
and prepare for the second coming.
However, nobody has ever shown us how to
study it. Do we just read whatever we
feel like or what's the proper way to
study the Bible?
Well, I would take issue with uh with
one thing that this question says, and
it says, "Nobody has ever shown us how
to study it." uh there are many many
useful uh materials to help us in the
study of uh God's word. Uh I just like
to mention one that we have produced
here at secrets unsealed. Uh in our
first anchor school of theology uh I
think it was in 2014 if I'm not
mistaken. Uh I did a series called the
nuts and bolts of Bible prophecy. How to
study Bible prophecy. and we analyzed I
think it was like 15 or 16 principles
that we need to apply to the study of
Bible prophecy. Uh now those principles
apply also to the study of other
passages of scripture. So, I would
encourage you if you want to know how to
study the Bible, the nuts and bolts of
how to study that you uh go uh and
download our app so that you can read it
for free or if you want a hard copy,
it's two volumes. Uh you can order uh
these materials from Secrets Unsealed.
But, uh I'd like to know uh your opinion
on how to study the Bible. What
principles can we apply to the study of
the Bible? Okay. What what comes to
mind? I just want to put out this little
commercial. This this ministry was begun
as an effort to fortify the st the
saints in their defense of their faith.
Uh it has suffered a little mission
creep over the years because it it's
also evangelistic. Uh it's also bringing
new souls into the kingdom. But uh your
original burden was to get the saints
strong to know what they believe so they
could defend their faith. Um, so Bible
study is is a an important part of our
of our of our our belief system. I'm
sure all of us have somewhere in our
notes Isaiah 28. Um, if we don't, we
probably do, which which says uh, here a
little, there a little, precept upon
precept. What that's saying is basically
you don't you don't take or develop a
doctrinal premise from one point in the
Bible. You try to find that idea
repeated throughout the Bible. You you
put them all together. You put them in a
blender and then you come out with
lemonade. In other words, you you join
all of these things together and then
let that inform your final decision. A
little from the Old Testament, a little
from the New Testament. Wherever you can
find uh something that impacts upon that
particular doctrinal point, you put that
in. Let it have its weight. So if you
see something in Isaiah,
don't just take Isaiah because the Bible
speaks about that point someplace else.
So gather all your materials together.
And that's basically the way you can
study the Bible. You can read the Bible
for inspiration. But the true benefit is
when you study. So you search the Bible
to find uh your belief systems and
before you plant your feet, make sure
you have the full picture that the Bible
is giving. That is one way to study the
word. Amen. Amen. I adding to what
pastor C is mentioning I think that it's
important that I mean in the answering
to will he has this sincere question
nobody has taught him how to study the
Bible and maybe that's the case sadly in
other individuals of the church uh it is
important that the church and the
leaders of the church take time to teach
people how to study the Bible in the
case that there's no such a experience
happening there. Uh this is why we have
a Sabbath school, you know, and the and
the lesson of the Sabbath school is is a
lesson that's supposed to help you to
understand or teach the Bible, how to
study the Bible. But ultimately, I think
that we have to come to first the word
of God and remembering that what John
14:26 says, Jesus speaking there, he
tells us this following. He says, "But
the helper or the comforter, the Holy
Spirit, whom the father will send in my
name, he will teach you all things and
bring you to remembrance all things that
I have said to you." It is the Holy
Spirit that we are to ask from the Lord
to teach us to un to help us to
understand the scriptures. And so once
you want to study the Bible, ask the
Lord first for his guidance for the Holy
Spirit to teach him to guide him and
then uh start with I would suggest start
with things that are more simple to un
to begin with like the gospels. The
gospels are very simple and just instead
of trying to read a lot try to emphasize
either a portion a passage of the
scripture and like pastor was mentioning
try to connect that with whatever the
other passages in the scripture that are
um that are connected to what you're
reading so that you get a fuller
understanding of one passage. I think
that it's important and it's easy and
it's engaging to study the scriptures in
such a matter and uh after that you know
you can expand and continue to build
from that point but you could start with
like I said the gospels or Genesis is a
beautiful book to start with the Bible.
So there is there is parts of the Bible
that you can start with and then build
from there. God will guide you and and
continue to guide you in that path. Plus
use the tools that we have as a ministry
provided for you. you know, we have
tools about studying the scriptures and
and uh that's why we're here for to help
people go to the scripture to study.
Amen. Uh I think it's uh you know, let
me give you an example of uh how to
study the Bible uh from a topical
perspective. Okay. Uh just some pointers
because it would take a long time to go
through all of the principles. Um let's
suppose that you want to do a study of
the Sabbath in the Bible.
Yeah, that's a very broad subject. Yes.
So, what do you do? You get a good Bible
concordance, right? And it's been said
that Strongs is for the strong, Youngs
is for the young, and crudence is for
the crude. But, but get yourself a good
exhaustive concordance. That means that
it covers every single word. And um if
you're going to study, for example,
about the state of the
dead, you have to look up every
reference to the word spirit. You have
to look every reference to the word
soul, every reference to the word body.
That would be that would be an
exhaustive and exhausting endeavor. But
if you want to have the complete picture
of what the Bible has to say about that
subject, you have to do an exhaustive
study. Yes. And then uh you know, you're
going to discard some of the references
because they're not related to what you
want to study regarding the state of the
dead. After you've done all of the
research, then you want to
classify, you know, what you've studied
and uh and you know, pre for example,
prepare sermons. You know, you might
deal with the spirit uh what the Bible
says about the spirit. one topic, what
the Bible says about the soul, what the
Bible says about immortality. See, you
have to look for all of the words that
might be related to the issue. Yes. And
then just after you've done all this
study, classify by category, right? And
then you have a complete uh picture of
what uh that doctrine is actually
teaching. You can do that with baptism.
Mhm. You know, you look up the word
baptized, baptized, baptism, you know,
all of the the words in the different
tenses, whether they're verb or whether
they're a noun. And uh and that's one
way that you can do study. It's very,
very rewarding and it's exciting.
Pastor, um uh one of the things that you
said if it's exhausting and exhaustive,
this is not a Burger King have it your
way quick fix kind of meal. You got to
put in the time if you want to
understand the word. The reason that the
the the Strongs is so good is because
you can get the the Greek meanings. You
can get the subtext. You can get a lot
of context that you wouldn't get in a in
a maybe prudence or a little lesser
concordance. But it's a and and I will
say this to both of you, as you well
know, once you start doing it, you get
hooked on it. You like it. Amen. You
know, because God has promised to reward
your study uh with information. You're
going to find out stuff that you didn't
know or you thought you knew that you
didn't really know. And then Ellen White
says, and I'm almost done. She says,
"Bible study uh increases one's
intelligence, you know. So if you're not
the sharpest knife in a drawer, you
know, you're not the brightest bulb in a
chandelier, you want to get a little leg
up, study the word of God, you'll get
more intelligence." Amen. Yeah. It
expands your mind. It does. Yes. There's
books that the church has made over the
years. Uh I don't think some of them are
published, but like Bible readings for
the home or God answers to your
questions. Those are topical books that
kind of give you some, you know,
references to certain topics that you
can buy. They're not very expensive.
Well, some of them are, you know, very
affordable. So, uh, try to find
resources that can help you to study the
scriptures. But ultimately, as you all
mentioned, you know, we need the
guidance of the Holy Spirit and and and
and sort of a concordance can really
help you achieve the result that you
want. And the first rule is pray for
divine guidance. Amen. That's the first
principle that you need to apply so that
you don't go to down the wrong road.
That's correct. And uh and when you
pray, say, "Lord, show me what your will
is even if it crosses my will." Yeah.
And so you have to come with a sincere
open heart. Yes. To uh discern truth.
Amen. Okay. Very good. Let's go to the
next question. The next question comes
from David. Once again, we don't have uh
the location where the question comes
from. would be a good idea to have the
location. But anyway, it's a very short
question and this is what it says. I
know we are instructed to pray for the
latter rain both individually and
corporately. My question is will we know
when we receive it? If so, how exactly
will we know
that? So, how will we know that we've
received the Holy Spirit when we do?
I think that the we need to look at the
reference in the scriptures
that gives us the experience of what the
early Christian church had when they
received the outpouring of the latter or
the Holy Spirit. And that is actually
found in in Acts
um chapter uh one and verse 14. This is
before the outpouring of the Holy
Spirit. And notice what they were doing.
These were the disciples and the
followers of Jesus. Notice what they
did. Verse 14, Acts 1. These all
continued with one accord in prayer and
supplication with the woman and Mary in
mother of Jesus and with his brothers.
So they were all
praying, they were together, there was a
unity of purpose. They were they had a
commission and they wanted to be ready
for to fulfill the commission. So they
they put aside their petty differences.
They emphasize in their unity in the in
the oneness to be prepared to receive
the Holy Spirit. And so they were in
that experience. They were no longer
trying to be who is the first, you know,
who was the most advanced, who's one,
you know, who was going to lead. They
were, they had this humility, this
humbleness, and they were one accord.
And then in verse chapter 2, verse one,
when the Holy Spirit comes upon them
again is the same thing. They had, it
says, when the day of Methus had fully
come, they were all with one accord in
one place. And so they again they had
that oneness that unity that it was so
particular in the in the time of of the
early church. And uh and verse 46 of
chapter 2 again notice what it happens.
So continuing daily with one accord in
the temple and breaking bread from house
to house they ate their food with
gladness and simplicity of heart
praising God. Verse 47 and having favor
with all the people and the Lord added
to the church daily those who were being
saved.
that that experience of the early church
is the experience that God's people will
have when they receive the holy the the
the Holy Spirit in their lives when the
latter rain is at port. there will be
that same oneness of doctrine
understanding their mission what we're
here for putting away their worldly
ambitions putting away their petty
differences and trying to emphasize in
completing the mission that God has
established for the church so that's to
me the reference that we are to have
into how we're going to know
the early church had the the blessing of
being in in one place you know they were
close proximate to each other We
probably will not have that. We will be
scattered. We'll be all over the place.
But the thing that will unite us is
we're united in Christ. We're united and
focused on mission. We're united in
surrender to the Lord. That will unite
us. And and those
are examples or or evidences is the word
I want of the presence of the Holy
Spirit. So that when you're surrendered,
I I am not at odds with you. You are my
brother. Um, we're focused on our love
for Christ, which binds us. We're
focused on our desire to to go out and
tear down the kingdom of the enemy and
build up the kingdom of our savior.
We're focused on that. So, there will be
a unity of focus, a unity of mission
that will unite us. That to my mind is
is unmistakable evidence of the presence
and power of the Lateran spirit. Mhm.
You know there's uh when you go to the
book of Acts
uh chapter 1 and verse 8 it says you
will receive power.
Yeah. What's the power for? You shall be
witnesses for me. Amen. Jerusalem,
Judea, Samaria to the uttermost ends of
the earth. A person usually we focus on
the latter reign as a personal
individual thing.
But really the evidence that we have
received the early reign or the latter
reign is the intense desire to go out
and proclaim our experience. There you
go. True. Uh that's why Jesus says you
will be you'll receive power and you
shall be witnesses. Yeah. You know the
prime example of this is the Samaritan
woman. Yeah. Jesus had the encounter
with a Samaritan woman. uh he brought
salvation to her soul and and what did
she do immediately when she received the
Holy Spirit? Because it says there
clearly that she drank the water that
Jesus gave her. What what was the
instant thing that she did? Immediately
she went to her town and she started
knocking on doors. I'm I'm paraphrasing.
And she says, "I found the Messiah. I
found the Messiah." Yeah. I found the
Messiah. Come and see. Come and see.
Come and see. And a little bit later on,
the whole town was following her. Yeah.
Correct. To to where uh Jesus was. In
other words, when we receive the latter
reign or the early reign, Yeah. the the
evidence of that is that we cannot keep
the truth in our own hearts. Amen. We
will go out and witness. That's the
reason why the latter rain is the power
and the loud cry is the
witness. They're connected. The reason
why you have the loud cry is because
people have received the power of the
latter rain or the Holy Spirit. So, you
know, receiving the latter rain is not
oh my little individual thing where I'm
feeling real good, you know. No, the
evidence is your passion for reaching
souls. And it's not even pastor also you
know some people have heard thinking
that the holy spirit is the the power of
the holy spirit is the experience that
the you know that apostles had where
they spoke in tongues and it was you
know amazing thing that they could speak
in many languages. So some people may
think, oh, we need to have the same
outward evidence. There's maybe
something that I will be able to speak
in Chinese or something like that, you
know, to to know that that God is with
me. But that's that's not the real
thing. You know, the main thing you you
will mention is that you no longer have
this desire for these temporal things of
this earth. You want to preach Jesus to
the people. You want to you want to
share your story, your testimony of what
the Lord has done in your life. and you
have a burden for souls for the saving
of others that is truly the Holy Spirit
working in your heart and has put made
you an ambassador of him to the others.
So, so I think that's that's the
evidence the clear evidence that you
have changed. I mean the apostles before
the their truly conversion to the lord
before they were assigned this
individual thing they were fighting
about who was going to be the you know
the first one in their kingdom. They
were competing among each other, having
envy one another. But afterwards, the
love of the world was taken away from
them. They realized this is not for us
anymore. We're not to have any desire
for worldly things. Our love is for the
Lord. So basically, you have to love
Christ before you can proclaim him.
Amen. Yeah. Yeah. Uh in other words, to
receive the latter reign, you need to
commit your life totally to Jesus
Christ. And when you do that, Yes. the
result will be a powerful witness.
People will see that you have been with
Jesus as it says in uh in Acts chapter
chapter 4. It says they saw that they
had been with Jesus. Um and so uh the
evidence that we have received the Holy
Spirit is the desire uh to go out and to
witness the experience that we have had
with the Lord. Amen. There are there are
two words you know as as you all know
for power. One is authority and the
other is dunamis which is physical
power. I think this is dunamis, is it
not? This one is is is not is more than
a thought. It's Yeah, this is dunamis.
Dunamis. Yeah. So, this is like fire
shut up in your bones. You know, you
can't you can't help but witness. This
is the physical ability to get the job
done and the motivation to get the job
done. So, this is not where you can kind
of sit and just think about it and maybe
read your Bible occasionally. This is
something that is burning inside you
that moves you that motivates you to go
out and do for the Lord. And that's what
we're all looking for and praying for
for the church and for our own
individual selves each and every day.
When the Sanhedrin told Peter and John,
you can't preach Jesus, they said, we
can't help but preach Jesus because it
says that they had been with Jesus. In
other words, if we have not been with
Jesus, we have no desire to tell others
about our experience. Yes. And so um we
need to prepare to receive the latter
rain. And the preparation is through
prayer and through Bible study. Amen.
Get acquainted with Jesus. Become a
friend of Jesus. Amen. And then pray
that Jesus will give us the power to
share the experience that we have had
with him. Amen. Amen. It's not rocket
science. You know, we have to answer to
the Lord the question that he asked
Peter. Now, do you love me more than
this? and and and you know sometimes we
have to ask ourselves, do I love
something in this world more than the
Lord? Do I love my family, even my
family, which is a God-given gift? You
know, do I love them more than I love
Jesus? Do I love my job? Do I love my
work? Do I love my career? Whatever it
might be, if you love that more than
Christ, you are not fully in connection
with God. But God wants you to give that
up and put God in your heart first. And
then you will have the experience of the
Holy Spirit being truly power empowering
you to do. Amen. Amen. I remind you that
uh at general conference we will have
booth number 107. Please if you come to
the general conference session visit us
there. We want to get acquainted with
with you. We want to hear your
testimony. We want to record your
testimony for a later broadcast. Thank
you for joining us today. God bless you
and we hope to see you at our next
program. I'd like to know.
[Music]